hey there two cents viewer before we get
started just a little bit of legal
housekeeping by watching this video you
are agreeing to the following you shall
not copy transcribe or publicly display
this episode except at an awards show
you may not disparage two cents or its
hosts in any capacity and that includes
comments about Philip's hair or lack
thereof you must subscribe to the two
cents Channel and click the
notifications Bell and become a patron
on our patreon page Link in the
description you will tell at least five
friends that two cents is your favorite
show of all time and if they don't watch
it you won't be their friend anymore by
continuing to play this video you are
agreeing to be bound by the
aformentioned terms and conditions of
this enduser license agreement for those
of you who are still here thank you for
being such disturbingly loyal fans but
alas this is not remotely enforceable
this however
[Music]
is
as a cfp I would ordinarily never advise
someone to sign a contract that they
haven't read but when it comes to ulas
or end user license agreements we don't
really have a choice if you want to
participate in modern society you
probably have to click I agree at least
a dozen times a month and the idea that
any of us would or could actually read
all the terms and conditions is
ludicrous iTunes agreement is longer
than Beth just to buy a $2 song and even
though we all check the box that says I
have read and understand these terms
most people would need an extended
session with a lawyer to really know
what they're agreeing to one study
estimated that the average American
would have to devote an entire month to
properly understand all the terms and
conditions they agree to each year if
you need any more evidence that people
don't read these things one games
retailer snuck a clause into their terms
and conditions giving the company a
nontransferable option to claim for now
and forever more your Immortal Soul over
7,000 people clicked agree 22,000 people
committed to 1,000 hours of community
service in exchange for free Wi-Fi and
when a software maker promised $1,000 to
the first person who noticed the offer
in the fine print of their Ula it took 4
months for someone to claim it most of
us have just accepted all this as an
annoying fact of Modern Life a
technocratic odity of the internet age
but ulas are just the latest weapon in a
battle that's been going on for a
hundred years a battle against ownership
rights in 1904 the publisher Bob Merill
printed a small disclaimer inside each
copy of the novel The Cast Away it read
the price of this book is $1 net no
dealer is licensed to sell it at a less
price and a sale at a less price will be
treated as an infringement of the
copyright like most Publishers Bob's
Merill saw used bookstores as a threat
to their business in a perfect world
everyone who wanted to read their book
would have to buy their own brand new
copy at full price and they thought they
could force people to do that by
invoking copyright law it didn't work
the courts struck down their lawsuit
because they sought as an attempt to
attach servitude to personal property
servitude refers to conditions or
obligations that are tied to a sold
property it's most common in real estate
like mandating what kind of structures
can be built on a piece of land but it's
not allowed when it comes to personal
property you can't sell someone a hammer
and then tell them what they can build
with it the new owner can use their
property how and when they want these
rights of ownership were codified in the
Copyright Act of 1909 it created
protections for the owners of
intellectual property like authors and
Publishers but it also carved out some
rights for the buyers of individual
copies according to the ACT if you buy a
book you can't make duplicates and sell
them you can't charge audiences to hear
a public reading or sell your own sequel
you can however resell the book if you
want to or lend it to a friend or give
it as a gift over the next 100 years
those rights of ownership have been
relentlessly targeted by IP owners
record companies tried to shut down used
music shops movie studios tried to
criminalize the VCR and video game
developers tried to stop the sale of
used games while digital technology has
created some real threats of illegal
duplication and piracy most of these
efforts are about control trying to
control how people use a product after
they've bought it time and again the
courts sided with consumers ruling that
unless people were making and
distributing illegal copies they were
free to do whatever they wanted with
their individual copies but with the
digital Revolution IP holders found a
way around the law ask consumers to
voluntarily sign away their rights to
ownership as a condition of the purchase
the enduser license agreement even
though e- sellers use language like buy
now and own it in 4k if you actually
read the terms you'll find that you
don't actually own the thing you buy
you're just getting a license or
permission to use it in certain limited
ways most ulas don't allow you to lend
or gift your purchases and dictate what
device you can use them on some prohibit
any kind of disparagement which could
even mean a negative review and many
reserve the right to revoke your license
at any time without a refund besides the
loss of ownership rights the shift from
buying to licensing has other economic
downsides artists make much less from
streaming than they did from physical
media and lack that tactile connection
to their fans the death of used media
shops May mean that lower in inome
audiences will have fewer ways to
discover music and movies which in the
long run is bad for the industry and if
switching from one platform to another
like say PlayStation to Xbox means
you'll lose your entire Library
customers are so locked in that there's
little motivation for companies to
innovate or compete nevertheless ulas
have become so lucrative for businesses
that they're looking to expand them
Beyond IP into more tangible purchases
like Vehicles appliances and electronics
anything with a processor can be loaded
with simple software that allows the
seller to control its functioning after
purchase coffee makers can be programmed
to only Brew certain brands of coffee
cars and tractors can be encrypted to
prohibit even simple repairs unless at
an official dealership and printers can
be remotely bried by the company if
you're late paying the toner
subscription fee ordinarily this kind of
servitude would be illegal the log
clearly gives buyers the right to alter
repair or resell whatever they own but
though you may own the coffee maker you
don't own the software installed on it
you're just licensing it which means any
attempt to subvert or bypass it is a
breach of contract if things keep going
this way someday you could get sued just
for loaning your lawnmower to a neighbor
but there is a backlash gaining momentum
known as the right to repair movement
more than half the states are
considering or have passed bills that
prohibit companies from inserting these
kinds of digital restrictions into
physical products and unlike almost
every other issue in America this one is
uniting people from both sides of the
political Spectrum turns out that the
vast majority of Americans believe that
you should be able to do what you want
with the stuff you buy maybe with a
little political action we can stop a
dystopian future where we're all
subscribers rather than owners but until
then ulas are enforcable contracts even
though consumers have no way around them
many courts have affirmed that it is
indeed possible to wave your
hundred-year-old rights of ownership
just by clicking on a box and unless
you're willing to opt out of all popular
culture that's what you'll have to do
but don't kid yourself you're not buying
anything they're just letting you use it
for a while and that's our two cents
before you go we want to tell you about
a new show on PBS Origins a people's
history of Native America hosted by
comedian and actor Tyler Clair it's a
miniseries that explores the current
social climate in Native America diving
deep into the history of tribal Nations
and the external factors that have
shaped contemporary circumstances
there's a link in the description we
hope you
[Music]
enjoy and